the hungarian bill is a shame
and i've instructed my responsible
commissioners
to write a letter to the hungarian
authorities
concerning or expressing our legal
concerns
before the bill enters into force
this bill clearly discriminates
against people on the basis of their
sexual
orientation and it goes against all the
values the
fundamental values of the european union
and this is
human dignity it is equality and
is the human fundamental rights so we
will not
compromise on these principles and
i have said it before and i want to
repeat it
i strongly believe in a european union
that is clear that where
you where you are who you want to be
and i strongly believe in a european
union where you are
free to love whom you want
and i believe in a european union that
embraces diversity this
is the foundation of our values so i
will use all the powers of the
commission to ensure
that the rights of all eu citizens
are guaranteed whoever you are
and wherever you live